[Musique]
on a donc appris cet après midi la mort
de jean-paul belmondo à 88 ans un
comédien qui avait une place unique dans
le cinéma français une figure qui
incarnait la foule la force l'agilité
l'humour et pour ça il va vous faire
rire et piccoli je vais vous faire rire
tous les matins qui même sur votre siège
à 19 ans il entre au conservatoire en
1952 sur scène ils jouent anouilh
molière feydeau mais ces professeurs ne
croient pas en lui l acteur très
populaire n'avait pas toujours eu le
meilleur accueil du monde du cinéma mais
le césar d'honneur reçue en 2017 l'ava
sincèrement touchés
je veux revenir et de tous de poser un
plot l'ismans un symbole droit donc moi
c'est comme si je me levais le matin que
je me baladais sur les quais qui avait
plu à tour eiffel
et si un peu ça la disparition de jean
paul il n'y a plus la tour eiffel et
j'ai un regret je vous lis et que cet
été
je faisais du bois
type
à
toc toc badaboum
voici la dernière apparition publique de
jean paul belmondo il y à un peu plus
d'un an aux obsèques de son ami l'acteur
et humoriste guy bedos bébel qui
apparaît très diminuée mais son sourire
si reconnaissable refait surface quand
la foule scandait son prénom jean paul
dans la vie il ya deux choses arriver à
un moment donné on choisir où je crois
une canne à pêche et puis la vie ce qui
est très triste ou alors la vie est
toujours formidable il ya toujours des
des passions je crois que la passion est
pas parti faut jouer tant commandant vie
je crois que on vieillit de moments où
on a plus envie de quelque chose ce soir
emmanuel macron évoque un trésor
national
un casse cou et un magicien des mots
nous nous retrouvions tous en lui écrit
ce soir le chef de l'état veut faire du
bifff de tamoul à
côté derrière après cet apprenti mais
c'est une belle chanson il veut faire du
bifff de la moule à du caramel c'est
beau aussi caramel je trouve oui ces
débats café sa salle à la nage il faut
arrêter de traiter de la comptal roubaix
c'est un mal à vous chantiez que la vie
me pardonne c'est un un des tubes de
l'année 1945 comme son nom
[Rires]
voilà je vous remercie j'ai dit je
pouvais pas marcher mais c'était beau
c'était n'étaient pas nés donc pour ceux
qui savent pas le savez ce que c'est ma
région
voilà exact un maréchal ferrant c'est
celui qui faire les chevaux tout
simplement qu'il défère équidés faire un
petit symbole c'est le maréchal qui mais
qui s'avère à josé josé ferrand
c'est un ferrand aujourd'hui c'est
différent merci je crois beaucoup cher
lido vie et puis sera là demain
également pour cuisiner
j'espère illusion leur mission et
non ne te lance pas
n'importe quoi et je suis allé quand
même on appris vendredi
c'est bien dommage
merci jacques guilbaud
les
sétois merci et par des jeux comme
d'autre part de phase i
chaud près
cv coup abarines je vais brûler les
étapes je vais directement prendre une
dame blanche pardon je crois que j'ai
pas dis compris je vais prendre une dame
blanc et gris ville voulait pas pour
dean avants prennent étude de l'institut
ifop ce sont les françaises qui sont les
plus insatisfaits sexuellement en europe
sur 5000 25 femmes européennes
interrogés en mars dernier 35% une sur
trois des françaises déclarent être
insatisfaite sur le plan affectif et
sexuel avec les anglaises et bien ce
sont les plus nombreuses à être
sexuellement inactive j'ai deux choix je
prenais un âge
c'est l'échec
c'est la
fdic
bluedirect ab je n'ai jamais fait de
chirurgie esthétique à mon vagin malin
va très bien j'ai 24 ans j'ai un bon
agent les travaux à
crédit
dix ans et c'est moi
ça en tout cas je dis est ce que j ai
profité pour dire un bon adversaire d'un
grand mère wipro mer
presque nicolas nous quoiqu'il en
regarder
on s'en fout un 5 sur 5 je suis à fond
dans la compétition car et avec ma
famille mais en fait toi tu n'es pas du
tout tu fais quoi elle part à l'epu est
désolé mais lass n'importe quoi moi je
savais qu'ils allaient défaire sur leurs
pieds mais je pensais que ça faisait
partie de leur corps je savais pas que
ça sent mauvais et que c'est vrai
pourquoi repousser l'assaut qui a poussé
avant ça j'avais réfléchi à ça mais je
croyais que c'était ancrés dans leur
zone quoi
oui je n'ai fait que du fer ouais ou
qu'on leur met des qui sont pied un truc
et que ça se relève jamais bon en fait
que faut savoir que voilà parfois quand
je parle d'un folle parce qu'à part le
cerveau elle passe directement par la
mouche d'après une réplique des tontons
flingueurs qui ose tout et c'est même à
ça qu'on les reconnaît nico
et voilà m et me voilà
évidemment que nous on veut pas qu'ils
partent thibault c'est notre papa ils
tendent à anono bon conseil si le mental
de l'équipe et on n'a personne d'autre a
envoyé à partie beau turler preuve
d'intelligence on est tous bêtes et
méchants sont si mauvais si moi bien six
mois
[Rires]
c'est vous vois
c'est vous m'aviez connu pour fâcher
choisi un titre simple à dire la
rigolade c'est ce qui fait que ces
sommes sont soudés aussi bien dans leurs
loisirs qu'en mission
[Applaudissements]
est ici quand on se détend on le fait
avec une certaine élégance
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez les instants
pour saluer nos téléspectateurs en flore
est également l'indulgence demain on
fera mieux